[Music] there are
people who dream of changing their
lives and there are those who like me decide to
do it he
is my best friend gifts they
have lived in los angeles for 5 years
and 3 years that sexually death of
babies I do  yoga the therapies for
his part that we end up on applications
that even so
I found you him for tomorrow on me
it's like pancakes and b the first one
she's always fair is obliged to
eat on the first cream
you think  too much in the French way shows her
quest it's still a
fighter jet of young people like noah you get out
a bit of stupid herbal tea I would like to
let fate do it if Cinderella
had let fate do it she
would still be in the process of  cleaning up at
his mother-in-law's house and talking to
little mice
it's so great to be anonymous
touched with an anonymous
it's just another way of being
spiritual in the process or in fact it's very
physical a  anyway
[Music]